des textes en français et en allemand
des photos pour raconter l'histoire
tourmentée des relations entre les deux
pays
l'exposition présentée actuellement à
saint-cyr-l'ecole revient sur la volonté
de deux hommes le général de gaulle et
le chancelier konrad adenauer d'établir
enfin une paix durable
vingt ans après la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est à partir de la
réconciliation entre ces deux nations
qui se sont déchirées que tous les
autres peuples européens pouvaient se
réconcilier et former une unité
européenne
l'exposition détaille les nombreux
voyages des deux hommes en allemagne et
en france jusqu'à la signature du traité
de l'elysée le 22 janvier 1963 qui
consacre le rapprochement des deux pays
une étape importante de la construction
de l'europe
le traité de l'élysée ils transforment
en actes juridiques
il concrétise la collaboration désormais
entre les deux pays le rapprochement
avec des éléments très concrets dans le
domaine politique dans le domaine
économique dans le domaine culturel
alors que la ville va fêter l'année
prochaine les dix ans de son jumelage
avec la ville de bourges stats
cette exposition permet également au
grand public de comprendre de
l'importance des échanges entre les deux
pays
il était important aussi que lorsque
l'on voit que certains remettent
l'europe en cause de rappeler que c'est
l'amitié entre la france et l'allemagne
qui est le ciment fondateurs de l'europe
samedi 13 mai une conférence aura lieu à
l'hôtel de ville avec le président des
amis de la fondation charles de gaulle